[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité elles sont de
retour depuis la fin de la pandémie les
nuisances causées par le trafic aérien
ont repris de plus belle à proximité de
l'aéroport Charles de Gaulle des
habitants tentent de limiter leur impact
nous expliquera via 95 dès le début de
ce journal des bornes communicantes pour
prévenir les incendies la rédaction de
TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest nous
fera découvrir ce nouveau dispositif
déployé pour la première fois en France
à l'approche de l'été un concert de
métal dans la cour de l'école LM TV
Sarthe nous racontera l'histoire d'un
drôle de projet éducatif de la musique
saturée pour casser quelques idées
reçues et puis enfin d'édition nous
irons tutoyer les nuages dans les Vosges
avec une compétition amateur de
parapente de très très belles images à
découvrir en fin de ce journal donc
ce sont des bruits qui ne trompent pas
quand au retour au monde d'avant un peu
plus de trois ans après le début de la
crise sanitaire le trafic aérien repart
à la hausse partout dans le monde
conséquence les nuisances du secteur ont
fait elles aussi le retour exemple dans
le Val-d'Oise ou des habitants se
mobilisent pour tenter d'obtenir une
réduction du nombre de vols quotidiens
reportage et explication de la rédaction
de via 95 regardez
des avions matin midi et soir
365 jours par an c'est le quotidien de
cet habitant de la vallée de Montmorency
des avions qui passent au-dessus de son
jardin un rythme soutenu on a un avion
toutes les minutes minute et demi aux
heures de pointe et dans le meilleur des
cas un espacement de 3 à 5 minutes entre
deux avions c'est à peu près 430 avions
par jour du bruit mais aussi de la
pollution qui deviennent difficilement
supportable avec l'arrivée des beaux
jours c'est un peu comme le supplice de
la goutte d'eau si vous voulez ces
avions qui passent sans cesse
je sais que moi ça décourage la famille
de manger dehors quand on veut faire un
barbecue en général mes enfants me
disent au bout de 5 minutes on rentre
parce que c'est insupportable pouvoir
ouvrir ses fenêtres et faire rentrer un
peu d'air frais bon bah ici on fait
rentrer des particules ultra fine des
résidus de kérosène à brûlé c'est
formidable il y a bien eu un cours rép
souvent dans la crise covid mais cette
année le trafic est revenu à son niveau
de 2019 et devrait même continuer à
augmenter alors pour cette association
de riverains d'aéroport il n'y a qu'une
solution et limitée les mouvements
d'avion en 2019 on avait à peu près
500000 mouvements d'avion dans l'année
on souhaite que ce nombre soit réduit à
440 000 soit une baisse d'environ 12% du
trafic le 9 mai dernier association est
élu ont rencontré le ministre des
Transports qui s'est engagé à étudier le
plafonnement des vols ainsi que les
horaires de couvre-feu mais les
associations restent prudentes et
attendent de voir la mise en place de
mesures concrètes comme au Pays-Bas où
l'aéroport d'Amsterdam a récemment
plafonné son trafic en dessous du niveau
d'avant covid
voilà et s'il y a bien malheureusement
un autre domaine où les choses se sont
accélérées depuis la fin du covid c'est
le nombre d'incendies en forêt et pour
tenter de ne pas revivre les feux de
l'été dernier les collectivités locales
multiplient les initiatives dernier
exemple en date en Gironde ou une
commune vient d'installer des bornes
communicantes à l'entrée de son massif
forestier une première en France vous
allez le voir objectif interpeller les
promeneurs et les passants en leur
donnant quelques informations utiles
précisions de Diane douzillé pour TV7 la
chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
si vous circulez à vélo sur la presse
île du Cap Ferret tendez l'oreille notre
massif forestier et fragile il est
interdit de fumer d'utiliser du feu de
pratiquer le camping isolé ce n'est pas
votre conscience qui vous rappelle alors
mais bien cette borne communicante munie
d'un détecteur de mouvement elle délivre
des messages de prévention lorsqu'elle
détecte votre présence à 3 mètres des
messages adaptés en temps réel en
fonction du niveau d’alerte une première
en France plutôt bien accueillie par ses
passants super
ça n'empêchera pas les gens de mettre le
feu malheureusement ni dit de fumer ni
quoi que ce soit à l'époque nous vivons
vu les incivilités cela va être
compliqué mais c'est bien c'est bien moi
quand les gens rentrent de massifacés
ils ont l'information du risque et s'il
est autorisé pas autorisé ce qu'il faut
savoir que en fonction des risques
notamment le risque
sévère jus sévère donc en orange le
massif forestier est interdit que de 14h
à 22h au moins là cette borne il y a
beaucoup plus de réactivité comme ça 14
heures elle délivre le message comme
quoi on a en risque sévère fonctionnant
à l'énergie solaire seront installés
dans le massif forestier sur toute la
commune de Lège-Cap-Ferret d'ici l'été
les emplacements sont stratégiques sur
des pistes CD carrefour de pistes
cyclables en forêt ces bords ont été
financés pour moitié par des subventions
au total la commune de Lège-Cap-Ferret a
investi 200000 euros dans la lutte
contre les incendies
et évidemment ne le répétera jamais
assez soyez vigilants lors de vos
balades en forêt cet été alors nous
Montebourg était l'invité jeudi matin de
l'émission Face au territoire sur TV5
Monde l'ancien ministre de l'Économie et
désormais entrepreneur c'est notamment
exprimé sur la situation économique du
pays regardez cet extrait de son
interview
d'une certaine manière je ne peux que me
réjouir d'une part des 50 milliards de
du plan France relance qui permet de
financer la renaissance de l'industrie
on ne peut que se réjouir que les
investissements étrangers sur le
territoire national mais en vérité on ne
l'objectif pour la réindustrialisation
des carbonées notre pays c'est
l'équivalent disons les choses c'est
l'équivalent entre de relocaliser entre
50 et 70 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
sur notre territoire donc c'est entre
500 et 1000 usines celle qu'on a perdu
dans la grande crise de 2008-2009 qu'on
a pas retrouvé
là où les Allemands ont préservé ont mis
du chômage technique du quoi qu'il en
coûte avant l'heure du covid ils avaient
fait ça il payait les ouvrières Spain
les
usines qui avaient rien à faire mais
nous on les a mis à la casse et eux ils
ont gardé conséquences ils ont ils ont
ils ont 23% du PIB mais consacré à
l'industrie donc attendez attendez 50 à
70 milliards de relocalisation on ne le
fera pas avec seulement l'état on le
fera avec les milliers de PME sur le
territoire qui ont des projets dans leur
carton qui ne sont pas financés par le
système bancaire donc il va falloir
réformer
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui dans la tête
des entrepreneurs en mesure de faire
naître et où il n'y a pas parce qu'il y
a des problèmes de recrutement
considérable puisque on n'arrive pas
aujourd'hui à recruter déjà dans les
industries existantes comme on va faire
pour la nouvelle agriculture la nouvelle
industrie face au territoire avec Arnaud
Montebourg et avoir ou à revoir sur le
site internet de TV5 Monde et des
partenaires de l'émission Ouest-France
Nice-Matin 20 minutes la montagne le
magazine Le Point et France Antilles
France Antilles justement parlons-en
avec cette nouveauté pour le quotidien à
partir du 20 juin prochain le journal
sera de nouveau imprimé à Pointe-à-Pitre
en Guadeloupe le groupe vient d'acquérir
une toute nouvelle presse entièrement
numérique qui lui permettra d'imprimer
également les journaux nationaux les
détails avec ce reportage de Christophe
Rigaud
il y a un an consenti installé une toute
nouvelle imprimerie numérique en
Martinique aujourd'hui sur ces palettes
c'est au tour de la Guadeloupe de voir
arriver cette presse flambant neuve
France anti pourra désormais imprimer
sur place son journal grâce à cette
machine dernier cri une nouvelle
imprimerie qui permettra de conforter la
présence d'une presse locale papier dans
les Antilles nous sommes en lien social
je prends l'exemple en Guyane nous
avions arrêté le papier donc quand on
avait repris de papier était arrêté on
l'a relancé il y a à peu près trois mois
donc on sort en Hebdo et on va 2500
journaux toutes les semaines donc ça
veut bien dire qu'il y a une appétence
l'arrivée de cette imprimerie
entièrement numérique va également
permettre à France anti de se développer
en plus de son édition locale on va
imprimer toute la prestationale donc on
m'a imprimé un jour J le monde les échos
le Parisien
l'équipe toutes les on va dire tous les
les journaux nationaux qui étaient
acheminés deux fois par semaine par
avion installé cette presse venue des
États-Unis en Guadeloupe a également été
un défi logistique
à la manœuvre pour convoyer déballer et
assembler la presse il y a cette
entreprise spécialisée dans le transport
maritime savoir faire à la fois dans la
partie technique c'est-à-dire des balais
approchés sur le site de production mais
également dans une expertise douanière
qui est quelque chose d'important car il
faut respecter l'ensemble des procédures
voire même de concilier et surtout
conseiller notre client après une
période de test la nouvelle imprimerie
numérique de France Antilles devrait
sortir ses premières éditions à partir
du 20 juin prochain ils sont les
contrôleurs de la Marine nationale les
guetteurs sémaphoriques c'est leur nom
exerce un métier méconnu du grand public
mais néanmoins essentiel pour la
sécurité des côtes françaises et c'est
pour mieux faire connaître cette
profession que des portes ouvertes et
tout organisées il y a quelques jours
dans le Finistère objectif attirer les
candidats pour pallier les difficultés
de recrutement un sujet de Maël d'elmure
pour tbeo la chaîne du groupe telegram
sémaphorique ont comme mission de
surveiller les espaces maritimes aériens
et terrestres afin d'assurer leur
mission de défense maritime nationale
des sémaphores il en existe 58 en France
qui sont à planter sur les points
stratégiques du littoral français en
Atlantique nous comptons 25 sémaphore
qui sont répartis depuis 5A jusqu'au
sémaphore de Socoa à Saint-Jean-de-Luz
la particularité de la façade atlantique
c'est d'avoir des sémaphores insulaires
comme celui du STIF à Ouessant
[Musique]
face à des difficultés de recrutement et
une méconnaissance du métier de getter
la Marine nationale a organisé une
journée portes ouvertes dans si c'est ma
fort insulaire du Finistère nous avons
trouvé pertinent d'ouvrir les portes aux
jeunes publics insulaires qui est
peut-être
peu de connaissances sur l'émission
d'essai ma force sur leur île dans le
cadre du recrutement local cette option
permet à une jeune recrue de se
positionner près de son domicile afin
d'avoir une première expérience au sein
de la Marine nationale un contrat de 4
ans mise en place par la main afin de
permettre aux soldats de choisir leur
affectation le temps de ce premier
contrat l'objectif recruter des jeunes
insulaires entre 17 et 30 ans comme Loïc
bon on en parlait déjà quand il avait vu
les affiches dans le bourg et de ça on
en parlait et puis on se dit pourquoi
pas aller voir tous ensemble c'est
peut-être intéressé de trois donc j'ai
jamais eu l'idée de faire l'armée même
quand j'étais jeune ou tout ça ça m'a ça
me dit rien du tout mais là plus années
passent et puis on se dit pourquoi pas
changer de style de vie une première les
portes ouvertes réussites selon
l'état-major qui envisage théories et
l'opération séduction l'année prochaine
voilà et elle aussi doit sûrement vous
être inconnu la pilotine est un navire
puissant à la fonction particulière
transporter des pilotes spécialistes des
entrées et des sorties de port à bord
des ferry comme vous le voyez sur ces
images de nos partenaires encore
télépaïsés un bateau et un métier
atypique non sans risque écoutez et ces
précisions recueillies par My Poupart et
Paul Claret alors notre métier consiste
à faire rentrer des bateaux ici sur la
session de l'île Rousse et de Calvi
c'est les bateaux à partir de 60 mètres
tout ce qui est yacht ou navire de
plaisance et surtout le commerce et les
faire rentrer en sécurité c'est surtout
des bateaux qui sont très puissants pour
pour
affronter les mauvaises conditions
météorologiques ce sont des bateaux qui
sont relativement simples qui permettent
de passer du portique que vous voyez à
l'échelle de pilote qui nous amène en à
bord en toute sécurité des bouteilles de
vin par centaines repêché dans un étang
il ne s'agit pas d'un trésor sous-marin
mais d'une expérimentation gustative
dans l'eau de vignerons et
ostréiculteurs se sont alliés pour créer
de nouvelles saveurs grâce à cette
technique de vieillissement très
original pour l'occasion 600 bouteilles
ont été conservées 6 mois durant sous
l'eau une expérience visiblement réussie
comme ont pu le constater ISAD Barry et
Manon Scarzello pour la rédaction de vie
Occitanie
des bouteilles dans les temps de Leucate
non pas pour envoyer un message mais
pour modifier le goût du vin on est en
train de sortir les les bouteilles de
nos amis vignerons que l'on a émerger il
y a 6 mois et voilà là on est en train
de découvrir un peu le trésor une
initiative de 10 vignerons de Canet en
Roussillon et de deux ostréiculteurs au
doigt ça nous permet de faire le lien
entre deux métiers qui sont assez
similaires mais on travaille pas dans
les mêmes éléments mais juste à côté et
du coup c'est je pense être très
intéressant de mêler les deux mais les
terre et mer c'est le but de cette
expérience à la recherche de nouvelles
saveurs plus de 600 bouteilles ont été
récupérées un goût différent par rapport
aux bouteilles habituelles liées aux
nouveaux paramètres de vinification
c'est la température par rapport à la
même bouteille qui a été conservée de
manière classique la bouteille en mer a
été conservée à basse température
deuxième effet c'est la pression elles
sont à 5 mètres de profondeur donc à peu
près un bar de pression le troisième
effet c'est le ballon de l'eau c'est à
dire que les bouteilles sont sans cesse
en mouvement dans l'eau la dégustation
des bouteilles accompagne d'huîtres
semble être un succès ça se déguster
une belle attaque le public quant à lui
pourra déguster les vins le 25 juin
prochain à Canet-en-Roussillon
le monde nautique encore dans ce journal
qui se met lui aussi progressivement à
la Révolution électrique sur le lac du
Bourget les moteurs thermiques de
bateaux de croisière viennent ainsi
d'être remplacés une décarbonation qui
s'inscrit bien entendu dans une démarche
d'environnement les précisions de Manon
Touati pour la chaîne 8 Mont-Blanc sur
place
après 6 mois de chantier l'Israël s'est
prête à repartir mais cette fois-ci avec
un moteur électrique le bateau pourra
désormais naviguer de manière décarbonée
c'est un projet qui s'inscrit dans une
démarche de transition écologique la
plupart des bateaux qui ont un anneau
sur le lac du Bourget en place de port
son carbonées ont des moteurs il y a
très peu qui ont des moteurs électriques
ça doit représenter 1%
donc évidemment il faut prévoir ce qui
se passerait dans 10 ans dans 15 ans
dans 20 ans
comment ces bateaux seront remplacés
petit à petit d'abord il faut qu'il y
ait une offre il faut qu'il puisse faut
que les gens puissent acheter des
bateaux qui soient des carbonés parmi
les 3000 bateaux du port près d'une
trentaine sont obsolètes chaque année
jusqu'ici les propriétaires n'avaient
pas de réels solutions pour s'en
débarrasser depuis peu un centre de
déconstruction a ouvert à Chambéry la
collecte du bateau est à la charge du
propriétaire qui le ramène à des centres
de déconstruction que nous avons agréé
avec l'État et la déconstruction en
elle-même est gratuite mais ces
nouveautés s'accompagnent aussi par des
changements d'usage la grande majorité
des plaisanciers sont propriétaires mais
ne navigue pas tout au long de l'année
d'autres offres émergent comme les baux
de clubs avec des réservations de
bateaux à la journée le bateau lieu que
je l'utilise peut-être 10 jours par an
pendant mes vacances lui va être utilisé
pendant trois quatre mois puisque
d'autres personnes vont faire comme moi
donc c'est une solution qui avance un
peu lentement mais qui avance et qui va
certainement aider à libérer des places
dans les ports à permettre à plus de
personnes d'aller sur l'eau ce qui est
très important pour l'instant aucune
mesure gouvernementale ou préfectorale
n'impose d'en finir avec les moteurs
thermiques l'investissement pour la
décarbonation des bateaux de la
compagnie du lac s'élève à 3 millions
d'euros dès septembre la moitié de sa
flotte sera électrique
faire du vélo tout en restant allongé
l'expérience peut paraître étonnante
c'est pourtant à cet exercice que ça
donne tant ce moment même des
volontaires à la clinique spatiale de
Toulouse une expérience qui vise à
reproduire les conditions de séjour dans
l'espace et attester les bénéfices d'une
activité physique en apesanteur pour
cette étude ses participants comme vous
le voyez sur ces images de nos
partenaires de la Dépêche du Midi
doivent rester couchés écoutez bien
pendant deux mois les précisions micro
de Manon aussi
dans l'espace il y a pas de gravité on
parle d'un pesanteur ou de micro-gravité
et cette centrifugeuse va recréer une
gravité artificielle et donc on essaye
de voir si faire un exercice en état de
gravité artificielle peut permettre de
lutter contre les effets négatifs de
l'impesanteur exercice de vélo est quand
même assez difficile c'est tous les
jours le même exercice c'est vraiment ça
qui est le plus dur c'était l'occasion
de notre niveau finalement de participer
à cette recherche se dire que ça pourra
servir peut-être aux astronautes d'une
part et puis finalement il y a aussi
tout un impact la recherche spatiale ne
sert pas que pour le spatial ça aussi
sur terre finalement
il est l'une des représentations
emblématiques de l'histoire esclavagiste
en Martinique le neg grossir WoW est
devenu aujourd'hui un personnage phare
du carnaval sur l'île figure de liberté
mais aussi d'expression il fait l'objet
d'un projet photographique pour le moins
évocateur un sujet de Sandrine Claude et
de José et loi pourvient à TV sur place
métamorphoser on est gros sirop quelques
étapes sont à respecter
pas question de sandware directement du
sirop de batterie pour faire tenir le
fameux liquide noirâtre les corps
doivent d'abord être couverts de charbon
à peine travesti et va se sent
immédiatement comme transporter
l'essence l'âme des enseignants et
monter je me suis sentie vraiment
puissante donc là c'est vrai que c'est
pas une tenue que j'ai l'habitude
d'arborer mais je me sens bien et je me
sens pas
dénudé je suis habillée
sous l'oeil expert du photographe les
modèles prennent la pose m’arrêtaient de
poser et chez nos mains les jeunes
femmes se prête à l'exercice dans une
atmosphère empreinte de fortes émotions
le spot du shooting n'a pas été choisi
au hasard le paysage est aride fortement
exposé au soleil à l'image des dures
conditions de vie des esclaves c'est au
prêcheur que le personnage d'une
négociero aurait vu le jour il y a plus
de 20 ans d'abord un hommage au neg
marron qui utilisait l'enduit pour fuir
les colonisateurs et il est devenu au
fil des années symbole de liberté en
Martinique la liberté qui a été pu être
arraché par les nèg' marrons et ben en
fait c'est dû un long cheminement
intérieur un processus intérieur qui a
permis de surmonter leur obstacle soif
de vie de se libérer tout simplement de
se libérer et ils se sont eux-mêmes
sauvés la vie de magnifiques clichés que
le photographe espère pouvoir bientôt
exposer en attendant ils peuvent être
admirés sur les réseaux sociaux
du métal à l'école il n'est pas question
ici de matière mais de musique dans la
Sarthe un projet pédagogique a permis de
faire découvrir aux élèves ce style
musical et par la même occasion de
briser bruyamment quelques idées reçues
pour clôturer cette initiative un
concert était organisé doit lever et
cheveux au vent les enfants ont pu
profiter d'un moment atypique à l'école
Anthony piton et Florian Wozniak pour
elle MTV
leur musique fait bouger les têtes à
l’école d'Arnage qu'on sert
exceptionnelles de cryogénie-calcision
le groupe de death metal fait
l'unanimité dans le public
ça va vite ça ça fait du bruit tout ça
c'est voilà ça c'est fort c'est génial
ils sont saturés des guitares distordus
et des voix glutturales
une ambiance inédite dans une cour
d'école moi j'en ai vu quelques-uns tout
à l'heure qui était un peu timide au
départ et puis qui ont commencé un peu à
danser bouger les épaules j'ai trouvé ça
génial ça il ressemblait chose voilà on
a pu échanger autour du métal extrême
leur expliquer que bah quand même manga
il y a des démons il y a des sorciers
donc voilà chaque monde chaque groupe a
son univers et le but était de
vulgariser un peu le métal extrême pour
les enfants une vulgarisation qui
s'inscrit dans un projet scolaire le
death metal c'est le fil rouge et il
sert de point d'entrée pour des leçons
en classe tout en faisant tomber la
barrière des préjugés c'est on a enlevé
ce côté un peu diabolique en fait il y a
différents courants et finalement de
vous laisser cette année qui prend peu
de place dans le métal par rapport à
tous les autres groupes et tous les
autres genres et c'était aussi montré
aux parents que ben voilà finalement ça
s'écoute et en fait on a pas mal de
parents qui en écoutent déjà
et maintenant ce sont les enfants qui
s'y mettent certains d'entre eux sont
devenus cette année de vrais métalleux
[Musique]
allez zoom à présent sur un autre projet
éducatif beaucoup moins bruyant celui-ci
à Limoges le prix littéraire mosaïque
fête cette année sa dixième édition
ouvert aux écoliers collégiens et
lycéens ce concours permet d'initier les
élèves à l'écriture de texte une
introduction au slam qui vise à donner
le goût de la lecture et de la prise de
parole en public le travail de toute une
année était ainsi présenté sur la scène
de l'Opéra de Limoges imagé réactions
recueillies par Alain druault l'envie de
lire façades et l'envie de devenir sur
scène parce que ça c'est pas évident on
a plein d'enfants qui ne veulent pas
venir sur scène donc mais cette année ça
commence à mûrir beaucoup nous disent
que ça leur a appris à parler en public
cela aura appris à mieux parler en
classe également à donner beaucoup de
conseils et je suis contente parce que
je vais en ressortir avec plus de
connaissances qui me serviront plus tard
allez prenons de la hauteur beaucoup de
hauteur même pour terminer ce journal
avec une compétition amateur de
parapente organisée il y a quelques
jours dans les Vosges l'occasion vous
allez le voir de faire le plein de
sensations fortes et de découvrir de
magnifiques images aériennes dans ce
sujet de Louise hamunda et de Mathilde
Albert pour vos télévisions
et si l'on prenait un peu de hauteur à
plus de 1200 mètres d'altitude entre les
Vosges et le Haut-Rhin il y a une
dizaine de jours sous une météo
capricieuse une vingtaine de
parapentistes ont volé au-dessus de ces
montagnes pour un challenge amateur
point de départ ou drumons sur le col de
Buisson
après moi j'ai beaucoup j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup volé en fait ce qui ce qui fait
le l'expérience du pilote c'est la
pratique notre but c'est de rester en
l'air le plus longtemps et après d'aller
le plus loin possible et faire des faire
des beaux vols
c'est une idée après moi j'aime plus
pratiquer le parapente pour le loisir
car cette compétition n'en est pas
vraiment une la ligue Grand Est de vol
libre a organisé cette première
rencontre pour inciter les jeunes
pilotes à progresser
en entrée par rapport à une balise qui
se trouve ici aujourd'hui on avait
vraiment des gens qui commencent à
compétition et donc il fallait vraiment
leur faire un parcours très très gentil
donc là on est à 10 km d'habitude on
fait plutôt 45 ans km et lorsque je fais
des compétitions avec avec les meilleurs
pilotes allemands suisses je suis sur
100 km
on va leur apporter la technique de
comment faire une compétition avant
pendant et après et après on leur
apporte aussi le côté convivial il voit
que c'est sympa et ça leur donne envie
d'aller plus loin et pour aller plus
loin bah faut encore passer un brevet le
pilote confirmé c'était comment c'était
c'était court mais bien de toute façon
ça attendait pas à mieux là c'est les
conditions
donc on aurait pu rester encore des
heures là comme ça mais
malgré un vent un peu trop fort et si
tous n'ont pas le niveau des
compétitions officielles ces pilotes
auront partagé pendant deux jours le
plaisir des airs notre journaliste en a
fait l'expérience on vous laisse en
profiter
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi ce grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]